what caused you to leave the film
industry for what two years
two years i did to do some soul
searching
i i i needed a break i you know
i i got my first national commercial i
was nine months old
i had gone through the highs and lows
the riches and poor's been through a
divorce
marriage and a divorce rather quickly
and you know as i used to say my life
was trying to have a
like having a picnic at the runway at
that time in my life it was very
just very a lot going on it's very
turbulent
and i i was approaching 30 i was in my
late 20s
and you kind of hit rock bottom
emotionally
i wasn't you know suicidal i wasn't
destitute but i was emotionally done
i had been doing one thing and one thing
only for so long
even though i i dabbled in other hobbies
or career paths suggest
you know ideas coming up i had only done
one thing
and i i needed a break
i just needed you know it's one of those
things is this really what i want to do
is this something i want to continue
doing is this something i want to
pursue and put the next chapter or the
next 30 years of my life into you know
when you start coming up on 30
you do a lot of soul searching you're
not a kid anymore you know your 20s are
coming up being over and you got to
start thinking you know
things haven't gone as i thought they
would or i hope they would is this
something i want to keep doing
and it was the best thing i ever did i
actually went and sold
cars i went and sold cars for a ford
dealership
for galp and ford and it happened by
accident i was having lunch with the
owner's son we were good friends
and his father came in who owned a
dealership he came in he looked at me
and he said you look like
you don't look too good and he said you
look like your soul's been bought and
sold down a river a half a dozen times
and i said yeah it's been a rough go i'm
going through a divorce
going through bankruptcy and i'm just
you know
business closed down one of my partners
went a little cuckoo
and he said well why don't you come sell
cars and i said what are you nuts sell
cars and he looked at me and he said
you've been peddling that
crap you call art for the last 20 years
you made a living doing that
you got the number one ford dealer in
the world cars sell themselves
you never went to college you don't know
how to do anything other than what you
do why don't you
learn and get an education learn how to
listen learn how to sell he goes i
promise you when you quit here
if you decide not to stay you will take
what you learn here and be better at
what it is you think you can do
and boy was he right that was my college
education selling cars
what was that first morning like getting
ready to go to galpin
well they stuck me in a four-week
training course
so i went and learned how to sell for
four weeks under lou brown who was a
very
world-renowned car sales guru that used
to tour the world and teach
salesmen getting ready to hit the floor
how to sell
i could i always been told i could sell
ice to an eskimo
and we had 18 graduates in my
class and i was the last one to sell a
car it took me
three and a half weeks to move a car and
it got to the point where my boss pulled
me aside and said if you don't sell a
car today i'm gonna
tr i'm gonna request you to be
transferred or fired because you're
you're not you're not moving anything
and
there was a cop that used to drive by
the dealership he lived in palmdale he
worked at lapd
nicest guy in the world he used to stop
by and visit me every other day
and you know he would just he i
encountered him one day on the lot and
we hit it off and i
you know i have a heart for cops and he
was a neat guy and
i thought he wanted to buy a ford
explorer and he
would talk to me about it every day and
finally you know at that time my boss
yelled at me said you don't sell
he showed up the guy showed up that he
said you don't sell him a car today
you're done
so i walked out and he wanted to see me
and i'm walking around a lot with him
and i he looked at me and he said you
seem a little like something's up what's
on your mind you know he's a cop they're
intuitive right
he was a detective he's like what's
going on you seem a little i said
sir if you don't buy a car for me today
i'm going to get fired and he goes
you're kidding me your boss said that
and i said yeah he goes well we can't
have that happen
i like it in the blue let's wrap this up
never saw him again he bought the car
and never saw him again
the cool thing is i sold another car
that day and then i started to become a
good salesman it was just about doing
that
and that's what i try to use in teaching
a lot of the kids about writing their
first screenplay uh going on their first
audition
working on their first show shooting
your first
project even if it's on your phone until
you do it you don't know what it's like
and
once you do it it gets easier and you'll
fail you'll make a lot of mistakes
do it again fail again but every time
you do it you're not going to make the
same mistake twice it's like
i've been at this a long time i've been
a producer filmmaker going on 30 years
and i make mistakes every time i i make
a film i make i make
mistakes but i don't make them twice so
every time i make a movie i make a new
mistake
and then next time i know i won't make
that mistake again and you grow
you grow and and that's what i try to
encourage the young the young
storytellers coming up is it's okay to
fail
fail often get it out of your system
when did you feel you were ready to go
back in you had sold some cars maybe you
got your confidence back up
i worked i committed to do a year i
ended up working 18 months
with galpin and it was the most
incredible years of my life i'm still
very close to the ownership i'm still
very close to a lot of people i sold
cars with and i'm still close to some of
the customers i sold cars to
i was in 18 months there were some
issues with a manufacturer that was not
ford but that was very public
when they had tires that were ripping
off of cars
and i had sold probably 300 ford
explorers over my 18 months there and i
came into the office one day and had
over 300 messages on my
my phone after taking a weekend off and
it was customers freaking out
and i realized that um this is probably
a bit more than i
this is this is it's time and and that i
had been
nurturing that i had passed on two
movies that had come to me during the
time i was there because i wanted to
commit to to the family that that
brought me a job and
provided me a very good living working
there and an opportunity
but it was it was the fire debacle with
the ford explorers that was
the end for me that's when i turned in
my uh my name plate and turned over my
sales books and said it's
i'll give you two weeks and they said we
don't do that here you know we don't and
that's just a policy because they don't
want you taking customers in case you
sell cars elsewhere which i never did
but i that's why i left i was that was
it was time and i stepped right into a
great film that i did with my father
and uh never looked back and that was in
1998-99
have you ever thought about taking that
story of working for the car
dealership working for galpin and
turning it into a screenplay
i've thought about turning my
experiences into working in the car
sales business
many times um there was a great
film done years ago called suckers which
shows the dark side of a dealership now
the cool thing about a dealership and
gallpin is a first class organization i
mean they're
the best in the world what they do but
they're still the the people that work
there that make it interesting the
family runs a tight ship
they're the best in the business they
sell more cars than anybody but you
still have
the riff rafts and i say that with with
with
fun because what i what i learned is in
lou brown's class he said
nobody sells cars for a living because
they said i want to sell cars for a
living
people if you think about it everybody
who sells cars didn't grow up single to
sell
cars they failed at something else they
they went through a divorce
they they had hardships they lost to
business and and it was so true i
remember in our class that we had 18
people graduate 35 of us started
everybody else had a story about a
career that failed or a job that closed
down or a divorce or
a circumstance so you have these
unbelievable people from all walks of
life from all nationalities all
different classes
of financial and background and pedigree
but there was a film called suckers that
i watched and it
it was so scary on the nose when it came
to the business of the business that i
thought you can never
you're never going to touch that so i
developed a tv series
that when i was working with david
madden at fox i got very excited about i
was developing tv shows for fox
when david was there and um
everybody loved the concept they thought
it was great but you'll notice there's a
reason that car sale shows are not on tv
and that's because the number one
sponsorships of your ad dollars are
usually
car sales car manufacturers you know
you've got mazda you got buick you got
honda you got chevy you got kia
it's endless and they take those prime
time slots to
show families what they could be driving
so if you are going to tell the true
story of the business
you're not going to get those ad dollars
so i found through some really high up
connections in in television sales
broadcasting and
decision makers that you're not the
first who's come with the idea
it's a great idea that we can't touch
because that's where our dollars come
from
so but now that there's a streaming
ability i should recircle that you know
that's something worth
thinking about because you know if
you're doing a show on netflix you're
not worried about selling cadillac
commercials
this is off topic a little bit but then
glenn gary glenn ross was okay
wall street wolf of wall like so it's
okay to see
one sector of sales yeah but that was in
car sales
right it's it's the fact that buick if
you watch a network show
watch this as us i know you're probably
doing what i do and skipping through
your commercials on dvr
i guarantee you a third of the ads you
see on any show are going to be from car
manufacturers if you show a show
that shows the dark side of that
business how do you get a car
company to pay for ads of that show
you're going to have a hole in the
advertising
but you're right but those were films
glengarry gun ross was a great film
wolf of wall street great film but wall
street
is its own thing they're not buying ad
dollars they're just you know
pulling the strings of our globe any way
you like but
i i just thought of it as we're sitting
here talking is you know you can do
series for amazon you can do them for
netflix you can do them for all sorts of
different outlets
that don't require ad dollars coming in
so maybe it's time to dust off some of
those and
see and it's also nice because you can
kind of cross some lines and push the
envelope on those platforms too
you could do an ensemble thing like with
crash where you you focus different
different stories people getting ready
to go to his training class anyway best
thing i ever had happen is i remember
taking a family of six
i remember taking a very nice
conservative family of sex on a test
drive and a uh
i forgot i think was the wind star ford
windstar family
van and i remember
the father was driving and the mother
was sitting and i'm sitting in the next
rose with all the kids
and all of a sudden the father he's
doing like 55
60 miles an hour down to pulverton
boulevard he looks up slams on the
brakes
what happened was one of the salesmen
had taken a nap in the back of the
windstar
and woke up during the test drive and
father's driving all of a sudden this
guy with his hair all disheveled
it could have been a porter or somebody
popped up from the back
i mean that's kind of that happens at
dealerships i mean you're dealing with
crazy people walks like they're party
animals i've partied with you know
poison guns and roses motley crew and
van gaal and all in the same night with
charlie sheen on the side
and i will tell you the people that work
at car dealerships they can drink them
all under the table
i kid you not that's a whole different
breed
that's awesome sorry no that's really
funny that's really funny
that's a great story
you